now to respond is Harvard Law Professor
Emeritus and author of the introduction
of the published version of the mother
report Alan Dershowitz professor good to
see you tonight
why not fight this out in court in an
effort to clear your name well I am
going to I have to do two things one
defend the First Amendment right of
every American to respond to false
charges and second if the case does go
to court to show that she is a liar let
me repeat categorically she made up the
whole story I never met this woman it
was part of an extortion plot to obtain
a billion dollars from Leslie Wexner a
businessman the man who owns Victoria's
Secret her own lawyer admitted to me on
tape that it would be impossible for me
to have been in the various locations at
those times and that his client is quote
wrong simply wrong I commissioned an
investigation from the former head of
the FBI who concluded that she was wrong
her own lawyers withdrew the charges
saying it was a mistake to do so this
same woman who accused me accused Bill
Clinton and Al Gore and Tipper Gore of
being on Jeffery Epstein's Island and
the reports of the Secret Service Alan
no no he was never on the ever know he
was never there the he issued a
statement the other day saying he was
never on the island and Secret Service
records confirmed there was
discrepancies on other on other matters
with Bill Clinton he said he was only on
two flights turns out or four it turns
out there were six I mean he said Secret
Service's always with him it turns out
they weren't always with him when he was
on Epstein's plane so it looks jowood
but I wouldn't throw yourself in with a
Bill Clinton on this necessary to talk
about Al Gore let's talk about Al Gore
she claimed that Allen Tipper Gore were
on the island not only did Allen tip
accord not know Jeffrey Epstein but
guess who Al Gore's lawyer was David
Boies the same lawyer who claims that
this one
made these improper that there were
improper sexual allegations he could
easily have just called his client Al
Gore and said Al were you ever on
Jeffrey Epstein Island and he would have
told her what he's told everybody else
no he was never on the island he didn't
know her at all the interesting thing is
that Epstein is being prosecuted now and
they're not using this witness the FBI
and the US Attorney's Office and not
using this witness no does she have that
same lawyer that you said you have on
tape is he still representing her yes oh
yeah yeah it's David Boies who has and
his law firm have the worst ethical
records in the history of the United
States they have more ethical charges
against them than any other firm but
he's the head he's there he's the head
of the law firm he was charged with
unethical conduct in by the New York
Times in the Weinstein case he was
charged with questionable conduct in the
Thera nose case he has absolutely no
credibility but in this case he knows
that his client made up the whole story
and he told me that and I have it on
tape all I did is repeat basically on
tape what he had told that's the wrong
journalist Vickie Ward made this comment
about about told that told the cost that
would make you told Acosta he would make
mincemeat out of the women let's listen
the light that the Miami Herald shed on
the victims stories that were incredibly
poignant and incredibly credible
remember back in 2008 Alan Dershowitz
told Alexandra Acosta you know and told
journalists he was going to make
mincemeat of these women what does that
feel to that at all we had no truth I
met with a cost of only once with a
group of lawyers that would probably 15
lawyers and FBI agents they have notes
I'm sure it would confirm I never said
anything like that what we did say was
that
was no credible evidence that Epstein at
that time had transported any underage a
woman in interstate commerce and that
was required by the way Virginia Roberts
was not underage her own lawyer and she
have all admitted now that she didn't
start working for Epstein until she was
17 years old and that she doesn't even
claim that she had sex with the numerous
people she claims she had sex with
former American congressmen until she
was well well over age so she's lied
just about everything and of course it's
the job of the defense attorney now make
sure that the evidence is based on this
question but I don't do you still
represent know him and when did you stop
representing him Epstein no I stopped
representing him when the deal was made
and I haven't seen him in years and you
know if his lawyers call me and ask me a
question about the deal of course as a
lawyer I have to answer that question
look I was introduced to him by the lady
Rothchild the people he hung out with at
the time were the president of Harvard
the Provost of Harvard my relationship
was academic was academic we went to
conferences we had seminars in his
office none of us had any inkling that
he had this other life and as soon as we
learned about it obviously all of us
ended any kind of a social relationship
I then became his lawyer I'm proud of
the fact that I represented him I
represented a lot of controversial
people and we got a deal some people
criticized the deal but you can't
criticize the defense attorney for
trying to get the best deal possible but
I want to categorically against eight I
never met this woman she made it up
completely I will continue to say that
till the day I die and when I die my
children will continue to say it's a
total categorical lie all right Allen we
appreciate you coming on tonight
this story is sure glow civ and the
obviously the underlying allegations
against Epstein are horrific
I appreciate your joining us tonight